oh
bon
le courrier les chats de la maintenance
arrêté parce que nous ne voulons pas
encombrer les ut somme même si vous
mettez des timbres et 40 francs mais
auparavant je crois que tous les chats 2
tient tous les tout le chat de kien tous
les admirateurs et les fans des shadoks
seront contents car la france et
l'angleterre ont rendu quand même un
vibrant hommage aux shadoks
avant on choisissait le marbre de
carrare ou le bronze de barbedienne pour
symboliser les héros et maintenant c'est
la technique qui intervient pour
glorifier les shadoks je ne sais pas
monsieur rouxel si vous avez vu mais le
nez de concorde cette année de shadoks
une grosse influence sur la création du
sang cordes et est ce que vous avez
vraiment perçu le vibrant hommage qui
vous était rendu le jour où monsieur
turcat a fait décoller cet avion
magnifique vers les cimes car j'ai perçu
vous avez perçu 1 vous avez bien perçu
le voyez chez rouxel le dit veni vedi
persil est venu il a vu il a perçu plus
p